Speaker 1: Let's go next to let's go to
Rob from Richmond. Rob, you were next.
David, can you hear me? Yes, I can rub it.
Speaker 2: So I think global warming,
the whole conversation around it needs to be
changed a little bit. I think it's going to be
more structured. So, you know, I think Republicans
and Democrats can get on the side of protecting
wildlife environments. Why don't
we say like building kelp forests
near the oceans brings habitats,
but it also. Helps drag CO2 down,
and it would do two things at once,
but I think if you go to the minou,
it can get Republicans on board with it.
Speaker 1: I don't know. I mean, do Republicans
care about right? I mean, it's just not clear that
they. I don't know that that would get them to
care, presenting it in the terms you're saying. I
mean, it would be great if you were right. I just
I've seen no evidence that if we framed it the
way you're saying, all of a sudden they care.
Speaker 2: I see. I thought there
was danger that they care about
animal habitat and especially moderates, the
Speaker 1: moderates probably do. There is a
lot of right wingers who straight up say When I
hear about some seal or a shrew that's endangered,
I don't care. In fact, I think there's clips
of Candace Owens straight up saying it like,
I don't care about some salamander at all, period.
And so I'm not sure. I think you're right that
the moderates would be more amenable to that
type of argument, but I think they already
care more so that those aren't really
the type of people we need to convince.
Speaker 2: All right. Do you have
a favorite album by Soda, Estaria?
Speaker 1: No, no, not really. Did you see my
exchange with the 03:11 bassist on Twitter? Is
that why you're asking?
Speaker 2: No, no, no.
Speaker 1: Oh no, no, no. That was
that was bombed by stereo. Sorry. No,
I now I'm confused. No, I don't. I don't have
a particularly a particular favorite album.
Speaker 2: Favorite song?
Speaker 1: No, not even.
I'm not super familiar with their music.
I just I have them in an Argentinean
playlist that a friend made, and I don't even know
the names of the songs because I just hear them.
David, thank you. All right, thank you, Rob, very
much appreciate that. I really got called out
there. Yeah, I'm not not well-versed on the song
names. All right, let's take a quick break. If
you're holding, don't hang up because we are going
right back to the phones in a moment. All right,